inside Wuhan inside one of its makeshift
hospitals every patient here is
suspected of having covet 19 including
li shaohong
a 29 year old local when Wuhan was
locked down at the end of January a city
of 11 million people quarantined miss Li
started volunteering that work was
dangerous and as a result miss Li got
sick this is her being tested for covet
19 she transmitted to her parents in a
stable condition this is the first time
has told the truth and she's worried the
official narrative now some state media
was that the government to control
herself
jumping over formula but I'm sure now
Miss Lee says Wuhan has improved
significantly since then conditions here
are good with daily exercise have been
dispatched and there's plenty of food
[Music]
since we spoke miss Lee's latest test
for covet 19 came back negative
shall stay here for a couple more days
then go home miss Lee's story had to
spare her hope it's just one among tens
of thousands of covet 19 cases they all
have scars top Cheshire Sky News Beijing